nein komm mal schnell wenn sich das
nicht lohnt selfie dann wirst Du mal
wieder gekickt hier vom Server okay
Sandy ich bin da wenn es jetzt nichts
Wichtiges ist komm jetzt ja ich bin da
[Musik]
bleib einfach mal genau da stehen
du kleiner Sohn
[Musik]
Meister ganz schnell raus hier Sandra
oh mein Gott komm her ganz wichtig
Sandra komm her wo bist du hier
stell Dich hier hin
ja ich habe eine Munition an was
brauchst du denn eigentlich gerade
[Musik]
okay Sandra wir tun jetzt mal so als
wäre ich irgendwie ein Passant und wird
hier dran vorbei laufen okay ich habe
ihn so hunger auf einen Bratwurst oh
selfie Sandras bratwurstladen hier einen
Besuch ab
ja hallo
Nina
kennen wir uns
und noch
yes
[Musik]
halt's Maul
Selbstverteidigungskurs
[Musik]
Friedensbruch ich mache jetzt noch
sitzen mehr Möglichkeiten pass mal auf
Lisa
kann man sich Stühle craften soll ich
dir mal was bauen darauf habe ich gerade
Bock dann helfe ich dir dann ein
bisschen was ich mir gedacht habe war
dass wir hier so ein bisschen so eine
Bar machen hier an der Seite weißt du
dass man schön sitzen kann nur wenige
Minuten später aus
was meinst du
wie hast du so schnell die Tische
bekommen
siehst du mal und weißt du was ich mir
auch noch überlegt habe
schau mal dann kann man hier so sitzen
essen das Wasser schauen
die Wurstbude ist leider von Bakterien
überfallen spinnst du das war ich nicht
wenn man in Minecraft Restaurants
aufmacht das ist genauso auch ein
McDonald's Biom der Fall kann es halt
sein dass es von Bakterien befallen wird
[Musik]
auch zu der ist auch gespannt
ich weiß auch gar nicht was abgeht
was geht denn da
oh mein Gott
richtig ab hier
da kann man den brauchen wir einen Satz
Handy Laser luca hat einen kleinen Pipi
machen
halt erst gar nicht so weißt du und dann
halt mit Anwältin und so ein Scheiß wo
ich mir gedacht dachte
oh mein Gott wir können schnell machen
was kann man machen während andere nicht
da ist einbauen wenn man die einbauen
wenn die zurückkommt sage ich hey
minecraft ist irgendwie abgestürzt bei
dir auch so mache ich
Sandra hörst du mich wo bin ich denn
jetzt sandra ist der Minecraft auch
abgestürzt ja Digger ich war von mal auf
einen anderen Erde
früh fahren wir halt nach Darmstadt
deswegen heute bisschen auf locker
angelehnt
ist stimmt dann kommt da noch rein was
ist denn
was machst du Darmstadt
hallo hallo
[Musik]
halten
falls du mich hörst alt oder warte
schreib doch mal mein Schatz
alte gedrückt halten und dann musste
diese Fn-Taste S4
wird Minecraft jetzt neu geladen war ich
jetzt gehackt oder wie
Sandra hallo ja ich höre dich ich hör
Dich ich ja ich glaube mein Computer
startet sich neu oh ja du bist auf jeden
Fall aus Minecraft rausgegangen ich
glaube vielleicht hattest du einen
Fehler den den der passiert manchmal
[Musik]
alles gespeichert nee nein hast du
vergessen unsere Welt zu speichern noch
[Musik]
zum Glück Alter
Sandra
ja ab in die Tür
[Musik]
ja
was fehlt dort
Digger das war aus Versehen
dann setz ihn vielleicht aus Versehen
wieder hin
angetreten was fehlt denn da meine
Werkbank Madame wo ist die weißt du so
ein Ofen aus Versehen aber mit einer
Schaufel denke ich mir ja so blöd muss
man erstmal sein aber wenn man denkt
dass das Kino von der Stadt gesponsert
ist dann kann das ja mal passieren im
Gehirn müssen
warum
wenn aber jetzt auch noch eine Werkbank
fehlt die egal womit man sich abbaut
du bleibst
no no no no
du setzt diese verdammte Werkbank wieder
dahin bist du dann kannst du rausgehen
Werkbank und Ofen okay ich hole die ich
hole dich okay du hast eine Minute ich
zähle eins zwei drei
vier fünf sechs sieben acht neun
zehn
bereits wo läufst du hin
[Musik]
nicht wirklich jetzt oder so Leute ich
verlasse jetzt den Stream meine Mutter
schon da ach die schon da ja okay Leute
ich würde dann tatsächlich jetzt auch
den Server verlassen hier haben wir auf
jeden Fall den Weg dann kommen hier die
paar Tiere hin und so dann haben wir
noch was zu gucken hier drauf allerdings
würden ich dann tatsächlich jetzt auch
den kompletten Stream beenden
ich wünsche dir schönes Wochenende ich
wünsche dir auch ein schönes Wochenende
[Musik]